six middle schoolers versus one secret
fifth grader
in odd men out i'm excited for these
let's go middle schoolers i am a middle
schooler
i'm a middle schooler i am a middle
schooler i'm a middle schooler
i'm a middle schooler i'm a middle
one of them is lying who i don't know
they all look the same
what year is middle school what the hell
is k5
6 to 8 is middle school middle school in
sweden it's like
i don't know this means that they're
like 12 or
30 no what one
is a fifth grader oh that's it
they'll split a cash prize that's gonna
be so difficult plus they're kids if the
liars
they don't know anything they win the
entire prize
who is the odd man out
okay the hardest text i've ever taken
was s back test the spec test is
basically
ty going in hard right away love this
shirt as well
a two-hour long test that is really hard
and i absolutely hate it for me it was
um
oh he's a middle schooler right i
believe him because like they're a bunch
of people and like
they also like sound the same hamilton
he made a bank
george washington he killed some people
thomas jefferson he also killed some
people
from the beginning i was probably most
suspicious about
ty and so i just like kept my eye on him
why he wouldn't come in so hard it's not
time
it's not it ain't time how would they
know this
this is impossible i hate history
if there was could be no history in this
world i'd be happy for the rest of my
life
this is this kid's ranting about how
school is
history was like the most fun stuff it's
literally just stories you don't have to
learn anything
oh actually teachers make history bad
because they're like what date did this
event happen
no no no not just year we need the
precise date because that's important
for whatever reason like why why did
they do that why did they do that
i bet you now if they tested people on
the dates no one knows
no one has any clue win it they
should have they should have taught us
like okay
kind of like in a ballpark roughly when
did that happen
more or less you know look you're quite
nonsense oh
my hardest test was so i'm in sixth
grade but i take seventh grade math now
you know like six seven accelerated oh
yeah i do i do that
okay that seems legit let's see what ty
has to say about that
i was absolutely gunning for luke there
was something in him he was quiet
i feel like middle schoolers are
complete extroverts
they love talking well no i think that's
just
you ty it's like if when you're at
school you learn
like there's not much going on but when
you miss a day there's so much
like this and then you finish school and
you felt like you didn't learn anything
and i'm not really sick but whenever i'm
sick there's always a substitute
i hate myself use my substitute because
she will let every other kid do anything
by theirself like you could go to the
office you
go downstairs you you go to the reef
guys
i gotta i gotta let you know the ranting
about school isn't gonna help you figure
out who the fifth grader is
something that you accidentally left
wait you have recess no i'm talking
about an elementary
she said something about recess i was
like
you don't have recess
what the is recess i would be voted
out for sure what is read says
it's a tv show oh i love that show
that's weirdo
it's a hidden secret you have hidden
secrets in school
what break you don't get breaks you
don't get breaks in your school
what okay let's see what she actually
said wait you have recess
no i'm talking about an elementary she
said oh that's a bad idea to do that
they're gonna latch on to you
yeah no i was talking about yeah oh
you're done
my sixth grade is in elementary school
so we still do have recess
so i thought it was kind of the same for
her oh so they do have reese's i'm so
confused
it was it was really hard to talk
because i had
tie to my left teeth
yeah that makes sense bro stop talking
right now we're learning about the slope
so it's basically two dots on a graph
and you have to find the difference
between those dots
oh yeah i remember this slope too i can
tell you guys all about the slope
your turn
i wanted to be kind of the leader and i
wanted people to see me like
this kid's not the mole he is way too
aggressive well you're doing a good job
just talk the most and you're the leader
congrats ty
most people would obviously
be quiet but middle school i guess it's
right i'm guessing
it's time to vote wait no it's not red
yet middle school is a black hole
it's rain okay wait no this is kind of
burgundy
this is burgundy okay this is definitely
red now it's bed
all right i don't like kids that make me
realize watching this
whoa ty's plan has
failed
okay i think they're gonna vote uh uh
her i don't remember her name
what i voted for because
i mean i kind of could tell that people
were gonna come for me
so i had to go for someone i thought
like everyone was gonna vote for
okay myself that's me i'm literally luke
i i've been studying middle schoolers oh
luke you're done
ty you want to be in the old ones out i
was like sure i started
i started analyzing everything a middle
schooler does and everything
[Music]
wow that's so cool
okay so i have seven periods because in
our middle school we have that
it's not low study halls because we do
and
in seventh and seventh grade math right
now we're um
we did braid a change and that was i
didn't really i was the one where i
missed the day before
and i'm a sixth grader because
yeah play and uh pe in elementary i
didn't do dodgeball
and oh okay uh-huh uh-huh
and um uh-huh
best defense ever your honor i'm not
guilty because uh
and then i'm a seventh grader i have six
periods my elective is leadership
and i didn't be able to say this before
but my least favorite tests are
geography tests because there's so many
places and
that's a good point fifth graders just
like geography
it's like especially when we have to we
have to mark certain states
it's just really annoying trying to
remember all of it and then um
for um we have to run the mile every
week
and what else do we have
oh we are right now learning about the
byzantine empire
i don't think he's any one of them
oh okay what
nice okay luke's speech was better i
guess
i guess it's because a lot of people say
i look young
it could be because of my height or
because of my voice right it's fine bro
you will grow
to be six foot at least just like i
did don't worry okay you use this tick
tock
huh i don't i do oh that's something
elmo would say
luke are you them all i use tic tac
cause the girls always take my phones
and make tick tocks
yeah all right mr poppler all right you
guys went to
middle school like your first day like
what were you most worried about
well i hate my sixth period my my sixth
grade teacher
and i did not i actually liked him like
ty
i think i can really trust him because
he he like he talks a lot like me
the toughest thing about being in middle
school is the people that you go to
school with
because kids are sometimes really mean
and they're judgmental
but yeah mostly because like they said i
was annoying
same here i don't think you're annoying
i actually think you're kind of cool
yeah i like you so far when i got into
middle school that's sweet
how nice vote her out now dude i
remember walking into middle school and
seeing like the eighth graders i had
mustaches and i was like
i ain't here anymore i have to say
shave your mustache you're a child oh my
god i remember
weirdos in middle school had a mustang
like bruh
just get get that thing away from me all
right i was born in 2008 but i'm super
smart
i'm not like i'm not like one of the
like the short kids
like i'm what does that mean hey hey
what does that mean the one that goes
like guys
excuse me is you there
get her out get her out get it out of
here
thanks i feel like i feel like you're a
grown woman put into a little girl's
body
stop it child stop i don't want to hear
a single word from this
it's the way her sash was she was like
and her her emotions and what she did
kind of showed me it was like she is
very sassy and i and to be honest i kind
of enjoyed that
oh my god
i voted for ty because he was a bit too
outgoing and i thought something was
suspicious
yeah he was really really loud
i think tai is just 100 being himself i
don't think he's putting up
anything because i kind of thought he
was the mole
and no whenever now
i think it's one of the girls for sure i
thought like the end of her like she was
writing an h at the end and i was like
oh so we come for me now
[Music]
oh ty is going to be mad i get to like
say why
no no you get to leave tai i was like
what
yeah like i'm determined to find whoever
voted tayo
oh they have a little crush going a lot
and i'm saying and i'm shooting out
people people are gonna think i'm a mole
i realized that a little too late so
that's
that was kind of bad
it's interesting here i don't know if it
matters but she's the only one that
looks if other people raise their hand
but i mean that could mean anything what
is a myth that you've heard about middle
school that like
wasn't actually true like what your
teachers tried to scare you about
there's one
myth that i don't it didn't come from my
teacher it came from a lot of seventh
graders for some reason
and they're like oh people get in
trouble for kissing in the halls i'm
like jeez
dude this takes me back man i remember
like when you were
a middle schooler and you looked at like
eighth graders they're like
they're so huge like they're so
big they're so adult like
it's crazy so i guess like it shouldn't
be impossible
for them to find out who it is i just
they all look like children to me i
don't know
oh yeah it's a myth like you get a lot
of detention
for little things but oh yeah you guys
have detention in america
i would be there every day if i was in
american school
oh god oh god
in sweden we didn't have detention we
had this one thing though that after the
weekly class meeting if someone did
something bad they would have to
uh stay after the class meeting to talk
with the teacher
and it never happens like no one ever
had to do it except me
and since it happened to me like once or
twice and i was 100 innocent
okay but since it just kept happening to
me anytime anything happened people
would just blame me and i became a
scapegoat
because it's like oh i was the only one
getting caught by the dj it's a
stupid school and everyone just always
ratted me out too
like i yeah all right maybe but what
what is the hardest homework that you
got
that you guys have ever done not
anything bad
so much but you don't have to remember
anything with math you literally just
solve problems it's fun and stop hitting
on my
children you hate everything she forgot
the whole thing at home
i was so mad i didn't talk to her for a
week how many comments how many classes
do you have
sorry of six
okay are they gonna vote
they might stay here
okay they're staying i don't know i
don't know anything about her
i think i'm just a little suspicious of
her i don't know
hey it was her i messed up
i was like i should have raised my hand
it's definitely one of those two
it was her hey
oh now they knew it of course called it
on the hand
[Applause]
what i learned the most is to not trust
anyone
it's a good skill to learn at a young
age
you can't trust nobody that's what they
all took away
i'm gonna start watching my friends a
little closer and especially watch my
yeah because that that worked out so
well for you
i can't believe that i trusted the mole
i always try to look at the best of
people
and then they backstab you technically
she didn't you know vote for me but
still
backstabs backstab what are you on about
yeah get that cash well play
that's sweet i like that
the best part was like being able to
like meet new people
i made friends with luke um we're
actually all of them
especially sarah we might actually go to
the mall later
oh look at that was definitely missing
people
because you know it's you get you get
stuck in the box with some people you
don't know might as well make some
friends
ty was like really cool damn all right i
want to see ty reacting to this video in
like 10 years or something that'd be so
funny ty is everyone's annoying
she totally blew it with recess and
still won insane
what do the reasons mean ty's a kid at
sleepover that says it's tomorrow now
when clock says okay so
i watched it and i'm like god i'm so
sick of hearing about ty
speaking um i guess that wasn't the only
one
she was sassy and in my opinion i kind
of like that oh yeah
great episode very epic check out the
other jubilee check out you blaze
himself
thanks for watching and i'll see you
tomorrow in another video subscribe
profit